it's easy to lose the present moment
when you want to achieve something are
you able to when you take action just
honor the present moment every step
you're taking now while you are walking
to the supermarket you take one step at
a time so that the moment of arriving at
the the destination where you want to
get to is not more important than this
moment this moment is actually more
important than the arriving this moment
is of primary importance so it's more
important than arriving at the yet your
achieving your goal or arriving at your
destination when you're listening to
someone while you're having a
conversation if you can be so large
there that you can just listen when the
other person is speaking then you're not
losing yourself in your mind and the
Stillness is still there in the
background hey it's EV Carmichael and I
watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things too it's like your morning coffee
but for your goals kickstarting your day
with a blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you if you then start manifesting from
that deeper level within
yourself you'll be amazed how empowered
you can be in your manifestation
sometimes there is a Time Gap so
sometimes manifestation happens very
quickly sometimes you need to to as you
are
inspired a so to speak a
blueprint of what is possible of what
you or not so much you of what
Consciousness wants you to create may
arise in your mind and this this mental
blueprint of what you want to create
this may be there for a while it might
attract others with similar mental
blueprint and then at some point the
manifestation
begins some action may be necessary but
again the action that you take will be
inspired by the Consciousness and it
will not be
stressful this create this this is a new
way of
creating if stress comes in you're
falling back into the old
Consciousness this is a Joyful Way of
creating new forms and new structures in
this world how to deal with with an
exchange perhaps without being in a
business dealing without being taken
advantage of okay or exploited
yes whether it's business or something
else
the question is is always
whether what I sometimes
call the Transcendent Dimension is still
operating in your life while in the
background of your life while in the
foreground you talk
about business dealings with another
person or whatever it may
be if the Transcendent Dimension is not
there then
uh it becomes very
problematic and
uh all kinds of psychological
self-seeking and so on comes in and
interferes with what could be a much
more efficient way of even doing
business uh it's through
self-seeking and seeking something
seeking some advantage through the other
that a lot of dysfunction comes into
business
so there always two levels it's probably
easier to give an actual
example let's
say you want to sell something to
somebody um whatever it may be whether
big or small
uh uh maybe you're selling a a work in
the hospital business so Hospital
services for example yes
so you're always relating there will be
another human being
there you were talking
about whatever it is on a practical
level that needs to be discussed you
explain what you have to
offer
and the other person listens or asks
questions you explain
more can you the question is then can
you
sense we where's the word
empathy
meaning feeling your way into the other
human being to feel or to
sense the the the Consciousness that
is that which animates the other human
being the Consciousness behind the words
not what the person
says but the Consciousness that enables
those words to be
articulated in other words the essence
of that other person can you feel the
essence of that person but you can only
feel that if you can feel it in
yourself so while you
explain the the Practical side of
it you also there is an awareness
behind at the back of
you of this other human being as and you
you sense the shared consciousness of
you and the other your relationship to
the present moment
determines how the future evolves but
what we call Future which by the way
never arrives as because when it arrives
it's again the present moment yes so the
the
realization that all you ever have all
that you can ever
experience is intrinsically linked with
the present moment it's Inseparable from
the present moment your entire
life
unfolds in and as the present moment
that or there ever
is the the past when the past happened
it was the present moment it couldn't
happen anywhere else and when you
remember the past you remember it in the
present
moment the future when the future comes
when tomorrow comes it won't be tomorrow
anymore it will be the
now there was a a a British Po in London
that had I lived in London for years
they had a sign on the bar that says
free beer
tomorrow and of course Tomorrow Never
Comes so the side is always
true that's funny you go the next day
say no to Laurel also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there he that knows how to walk
interiorly and to make but little
account of things
exteriorly doeses not look for places
nor wait for Seasons to perform
exercises of
devotion the man of interior life soon
recollects himself because he never
wholly poures forth himself upon
exterior
things exterior labor is no Prejudice to
him nor any employment necessary for the
the time but as things happen so he
accommodate himself to
them let's look at those two sentences
very
important the man the P the human being
of interior life soon recollects himself
because he never wholly pours himself
forth upon exterior things a lovely way
of putting it the interior man again we
had that before it means it points to
the who you are at the level of
awareness the unconditioned being the
Timeless in you the essence of who you
are the interior
being soon recollects himself never
really you never the interior man never
completely loses himself in the in the
external he he or she soon recollect
himself because you he never holy I'll
just put it into slightly more Modern
English he never holy pours force
himself upon exterior things to pour
yourself into exterior things to
completely lose yourself in exterior
Things You observe it all the time when
you just before you see it in yourself
look at other humans around you how they
lose themselves all that the slightest
challenge comes in the form of a an
unexpected
setback uh something going wrong here or
there some difficult situation a person
not not doing what I expect them to do
whatever it is how
quickly people pour themselves into
exterior things things and so this thing
suddenly becomes of absolute importance
that that's what it means pouring
yourself
out into
things which ultimately of course you
pour yourself into your
thoughts every thought that
arises takes complete possession of you
you pour all your attention into
that so you a continuously loss a
continuous loss
amazing you can see it in others let's
just wait people around you how what
they do when challenges
come okay you've done that now you've
recognized in others the next step
is oh you can you recognize in yourself
do you do that also when wait for the
next challenge do you completely does it
completely draw you out of yourself
and when it does don't beat yourself up
but even just noticing that that's
what's happening is a huge gain in
Consciousness so don't you don't beat
yourself up and say oh I can't do no
just just notice it your any pattern you
notice in yourself means there is some
Consciousness there's awareness there
it's when you don't know it that it
you're completely trapped in it and if
you don't know it there's not much you
can do except after the talent has
passed perhaps you can look back and say
oh I completely lost it there
again and when that so awareness comes
after The Challenge which is even which
is still better than no awareness at
all and because if there's no awareness
at all even the most unconscious
reaction you will will justify
afterwards to yourself and to others the
ego is good at finding excuses and
justifications the most absurd
justifications will do it's an automatic
defense mechanism of the ego many people
don't are uncomfortable with themselves
they dislike who they are perhaps they
dislike their body how they look perhaps
they
dislike who they are as a person don't
feel they are good enough or are
self-critical a
lot they many people live with a
negative self
image which of course all consists of
certain types of Mind
activity and that's that's not
pleasant and it may be for some of those
people once they realize that they live
with a
mind
pattern that
continually criticizes them and dis says
negative things about
them they begin to realize that it's a
mind pattern this self
hatred is a mind
pattern and that it's harmful it's not
pleasant and they can go beyond it and
begin to replace it with more negative
thoughts about more positive thoughts
about
themselves and having positive thoughts
about yourself that kind of thing would
perhaps usually be called beginning to
love yourself to feel good about
yourself but it's not it's not easy that
shift from feeling bad about yourself to
feeling good about sometimes it requires
a lot of
convincing
I would regard loving yourself as a
perhaps an intermediate stage in one's
Awakening but the essence of the
awakened
Consciousness is that you go
[Music]
beyond
having a
particular idea in your mind that
represents
yourself as a mental self image that you
relate
to because basically it's it's
ego a mental self-image of who you think
this is what what I am this is who I
am if you want to learn about not having
a mental
self-image watch your dog or or your
cat they don't have an opinion about who
they
are they just are who they
are so that removes an enormous amount
of problems from their
lives of course they don't have the Mind
activity that creates a self-image in
their
head they are
pre-ind and therefore their life is far
less problematic than human life you and
see how wonderful it is not to have a
self-image you can even you can look at
an ugly dog or an ugly cat they don't
have a problem with
that even an overweight dog or cat they
okay no self-image the vigilance then as
regards your inner state is very
important so that you no longer believe
the outer is more important than the
inner that's the great delusion some
outer condition is more important than
conscious the State of
Consciousness so the the vigilance needs
to be there and I'm saying that to you
because there's enough awareness in
you for that vigilance to
arise without the vigilance you have no
idea what's going on inside you and you
project it all outside
and you don't even know this is the
essence of
unconsciousness spiritually
speaking many really unconscious people
they don't even know that they are
suffering because everything is
projected outward all the bad stuff is
out there other people and whoever they
they blame it's all out there everything
is projected they have complete
unawareness of their inner state that
it's the essence of
unconsciousness but even humans who have
already
begun the spiritual PA or The Awakening
process can still be taken
over periodically regularly completely
by the
delusion that something out there is
more important than the your inner State
of Consciousness and then you go in in
that moment you become
reactive
and in that moment you become identified
with the reactions which are mental
emotional forms that
arise and so you are lost and you think
it's it's all out it's out there this so
the vigilance then can tell you the
moment you become upset about something
do not be attached to the fruit of Your
[Music]
Action which of course simply
means
do don't look to the the goal of what
you want to achieve through whatever
you're doing now give your complete
attention to the doing rather than where
you want to get to through the
doing and that's again very important
lesson nowadays because most humans
don't know that yet they are always one
moment ahead they want to get there
you may find in your own life still a
lot of the
time you are not present moment centered
you are focused on the next moment that
you need to get to so whatever you are
doing at this moment is
designed to get you to the next moment
and
internally you project yourself away
from what you're doing now because the
doing becomes a means to an
end this is very normal everybody lives
like that whatever they do is a means to
an end and me in their mind the end is
more important than what they're
doing that is so habitual and
unconscious that most humans don't even
know that that is how they live that
they always live for the next moment but
they're never completely in this moment
they also don't know that by living in
that way they create frustration and
suffering and stress and
discontent basically they're condemning
themselves to continuous discontent and
to stress because if you ignore the
present
moment
continuously and ignore means you make
it into means to an end because the next
one is so important that you need to get
to then you miss life completely you
miss the depth that potentially is there
in life and life becomes shallow because
it's all mental because the next moment
is always a mind formation the next
moment is a mental projection the next
moment is never a reality because it
doesn't
exist when the next moment comes Okay
one minute from now I've got one minute
to finish
[Music]
this and then after 1 minute it's not
one minute it's oh it's now
again and then there's the next thing to
of course immediately you look to the
next thing because you have
become used to being uncomfortable with
the present moment condition since
childhood to feel ill at ease in the
present
moment oh I should be doing something
and doing
implies some future
projection you can never be you're
always doing as you get little tastes of
that state of Consciousness that we call
presence for example
now you feel yourself you feel your
presence right now Beyond
any
uh you beyond any thought that's
connected with your life situation or
whatever it may be whether what age you
are becomes irrelevant what gender you
are becomes
irrelevant uh what you have
achieved or suffered in this world it
all it transcends all that it is more
powerful than any of
that it liberates you from all that it's
not that the person disappears
completely of course the person the
personal self is still there it
continues to operate in this world but
there's a continuous knowing that there
is more to you than that and that is
vital so you continue to operate as a
person in this world but no longer
deriving your identity from the personal
sense of self you can operate as a
person you need to In This World In This
World of time past and future you can
operate in this world without losing
yourself in this world and without
losing yourself in
identity that ultimately is a very
shallow and fleeting thing that you call
me the
person so that thing continues to
operate for a while
but your challenge
is while you operate in this world as a
person not to lose
connectedness with that deeper
Dimension and that is bringing presence
into
every situation that you deal with every
interaction in this world and that is a
skill that skill develops and isir
presence itself is
timeless but it is a skill for you
to it requires some practice at a high
degree of
alertness to bring presence into
everyday life whatever you do here
whatever function you have in this
world
function and for example not to confuse
your function with your
identity it's a
function I am a teacher of presence you
are a teacher of presence or you are
becoming a teacher of Presence by living
in that way by
bringing that Consciousness into every
situation so that you
don't uh lose yourself in the doing of
whatever it is you're doing in the
situation and you don't lose yourself in
a sense of identity that's to do with
your function and to reduce reduce other
people to their function in this world
free will ultimately does not come in
until there's some awareness in you that
where Free Will comes from until you
have some
awareness uh you are run by the
conditioning of your mind and so you
have no choice the element of choice
comes in when you become aware for
example of your the thoughts that go
through your head and you might realize
suddenly and for some people that's the
first time they awaken spiritually when
they realize that for years they've had
a voice in their head talking to them
which could be a monologue it could be a
dialogue you could have a conversation
with yourself you can you can beat
yourself up and say why why you're no
good enough aren't you and then the
other part yourself well well I'm doing
my best I'm just I can't I can't do it
I'm not I'm not good enough the voice in
the head for some people the spiritual
awakening comes when they become aware
that there's a voice in the head and
there's the awareness right and the
moment there's the awareness you might
even be able to choose
to let go of a certain thought a
repetitive thought that you don't need
anymore that you don't want anymore and
then you you surrender it or you breathe
it out you don't need it you an emotion
sometimes people in the grip of strong
emotions but if there's a little of
awareness there if let's say it's anger
you suddenly anger arises but in the
background you're aware that there's
emotion of anger so there's a small
element of choices come in do you want
to then attack this person if there's
awareness you can observe the anger but
may may long may no longer need to act
it out I'm not talking about suppressing
but
recognizing the more awareness you have
or presence the more choice there's in
your life and then it's only then that
you actually become truly intelligent
because this awareness is not an IQ
thing the you can have I've met highly
intelligent people with one or two or
three
phds academics and others were
completely uncon completely unaware
still just completely in their minds and
and
people in their personal lives often
very dysfunctional personal lives uh so
it's not to be equated with intelligence
this awareness happiness or
fulfillment does not depend on any other
human's acceptance of who you are that
would be a deluded thought if you think
you can only be happy if these people
accept and understand you some people
have that with their
parents they so they say my dad my
father they don't understand me at all
it's terrible terrible I'm trying to
explain what I
add of course they they cannot
understand you it's beyond their
comprehension if you have awakened
spiritually and they
haven't so compassionately accept that
they cannot understand you instead of
trying to explain yourself to them just
be there in a loving way with them when
you meet for Christmas or Thanksgiving
and you hear all the judgments coming at
you from them you should have why don't
you look where it's taken you look at
your sister she married a mil
millionaire and
you and you are into that weird kind of
meditation stuff that's not getting you
anywhere whatever judgments come and say
okay I know that this is what you think
and feel and I think and feel
differently that's all so you don't not
need to
justify accepting people's limitations
and suddenly realizing whether or not
your father your mother your sister your
brother or anybody else Close to You
accepts you for who you
are is really not you become free of the
need to be accepted but you can
nevertheless have a deeper connection
keep that deeper connection and
connectedness with them I've had this
strange feeling idea in the past few
month um that a certain segment of
humanity is
uh uh losing the ability to think
rationally there's a decrease in whether
I call it IQ or whatever it may be
there's a diminishment of rational
faculty as reflected in many ways
on uh mainstream media social media and
so
on uh and another segment of humanity is
actually becoming more aware more aware
more conscious is not drawn into the
regressive phase that some of humanity
may be going through It's Not Unusual
for Humanity to occasionally
collectively regress to a lower State of
Consciousness it has happened uh
whenever a country or Collective has
been taken over by uh an almost one
could say toxic ideology that has
completely taken possession of millions
of people's
minds look at of course n national
socialism in Germany the maist cultural
revolution was quite crazy what happened
in Cambodia under
pulpot uh totally crazy ideas invaded
millions of people's minds and uh
uh reduce their ability to to actually
engage in rational thinking and uh it
things that happened for example in MA
China during the cultural revolution
um children reporting on their parents
when they were angry with their parents
all they had to do is go to school and
Report their parents that they had said
something against the government the
parents would be taken away and never
seen again they they went around public
parks
in big cities in China tearing out
flowers out of because beauty is
regarded as Bourgeois you had to kill
your back your pets your your dogs and
cats uh totally and these are just a few
examples of totally toxic and uh
irrational thoughts taking over people's
minds so that's to some extent I've been
seeing this happening uh collectively
not just in one country in quite a few
Western many Western countries that I'm
aware of and uh but it has not affected
everybody uh some people have managed to
remain aware they have not been one
could say infected by what one could
perhaps call a a a mental virus or
mental viruses that uh um reduce
people's ability to actually see reality
reality then gets distorted through the
veil of these mental viruses that have
taken over people's
minds um this is um a more serious a
more serious pandemic than anything that
happens on the physical level as far as
um uh pandemics are concerned the actual
viruses actually you might I don't know
if you've read car Yung said that the
greatest danger that Humanity faces is
not from any external Force like natural
disasters or uh dis diseases or
pandemics he said the greatest danger
that Humanity faces is uh Collective
psychosis for someone who's a little bit
hyperactive what's the best way to get a
balance between removing content which
is really
good but then not getting annoyed when
content comes in and you think oh it's
it's
spoiling my piece is there some way to
get a balance be more a listener than a
speaker make that your practice for the
time
being I'm not saying don't say a word
but be more like 80% a
listener than a speaker and that for
example you can do by asking questions
when you're in rather than stating your
view or whatever it is ask questions
that encourages the other person to
speak more as the other person speaks
more it forces you to listen and then
make the listening into a practice while
the other person is
speaking are you able to let's at any
time to feel your inner body can you
feel that the hands then seem to lose
them quite quickly okay but but hands
you can feel the energy in your hands
the rest of the body is more difficult
yeah yeah okay well it's a good start
it's a start so I suggest that once
you've asked a question while you
listen you direct your awareness into
the inner feeling of your hands yeah
thank and that keeps it there so that it
doesn't your mind doesn't take off
so you ask a question what um where are
you from how long have you been with
aard how did you first discover the the
books um have you been to other R many
questions you can ask and people will be
happy to help you by answering your
questions and they will be happy to help
you by not asking you too many questions
yeah no thank you that that's good yeah
that'll help yeah
so and so while you
listen have your attention in the inner
energy field of your hands if if you can
amplify that and have your attention
also in other parts of your body for
example your feet and hand at the same
time that's even better but hands is
fine too so you feel your inner the
aliveness in your hands and from there
you you listen and you
know just give
this will help you prevent the stream of
Mind from taking you over to take your
responsibility
for what is it that you can take
responsibility for
primarily it's taking responsibility for
your State of
Consciousness
which
determines what kind of world you
create you because you are Humanity
humanity is an abstract concept doesn't
exist humanity is the human being you
are Humanity so for
Humanity to take responsibility you need
to take primarily responsibility for
your State of Consciousness because only
a diseased or dysfunctional State of
Consciousness produces a diseased and
dysfunctional world out
there by world I mean the human-made
world that is has been imposed on the
what's already there the planet which is
potentially of course a
paradise the
planet pristine unbelievable
Jewel a being of great
intelligence we are not separate from
it but the being is going through a
transitional process and every
transitional process is critical it may
or may not work in which case the being
will go or some other way but
the your State of Consciousness
determines what kind of world you create
what kind of action you take and what
consequences your actions
have so here this is why my main work is
to address the cause
of dysfunction which lies in the human
mind the function of the human mind or
as it is sometimes called in Zen the
sickness of the human
mind
so as I see it and I don't think anybody
who reads history can doubt it there is
a
deep-seated dysfunction in humans has
been there for thousands of
years
and if we not if there's no shift in
that then the dysfunction will destroy
us it probably won't destroy the planet
because the planet has enormous
resources but it'll take a while would
take a while for the planet to
recover all you have to do then is
primarily take responsibility for your
State of Consciousness
now
now and this is what the entire teaching
really is about what is what is my state
of consciousness at this moment moment
am I
generating disturbance am I
generating
negativity am I generating conflict and
suffering for myself and others am I
generating inner pollution am I
polluting my beautiful the beautiful
being that I
am with
continuous
absurd movements of thought
producing negative emotions producing an
entire
entity that is illusory that I call the
me so to take responsibility there needs
to be just of course an Awakening where
you can say okay I will take
responsibility
now some people don't know that there is
even the possibility of taking
responsibility that's why you are so
important anybody who realizes
it this is you are the beginning of
the transformed World affirmations are
if they are done rightly can be very
beautiful substitutes for
prayers
um I'm Healed and whole and at
peace and after that let there be a
space
and really the power is in that space in
the space you experience that you
already
whole the outward form might tell you
something
different I'm holy caus in Miracle says
I am Holy for example that's again you
are and so it's simply an
affirmation of how it this is how it
is or if you ex healing for somebody
else
you either with that
person or that person comes into your
mind you're thinking about that person
and that person may be
ill and then the most powerful healing I
find is to
be to hold the image of that person and
then go deeper into
yourself where the wholeness of Life
lies
where nothing is needed nothing is needs
to be added and there you you find the
wholeness also of that person they're
already healed at that deepest level
Beyond form they're already healed so
you go from
form and then into formlessness be
aligned with the present moment rather
than carry in your
head this huge amount of mental
content about your past and your
future because the mind is primarily
concerned with past and future so while
you're walking here you're already
thinking about in a week's time I'll be
home again and then what then I'll have
to do that and I have those phone calls
to make and then I'll have to do that
and then those problems will be I I
shouldn't have come here because I've
got Ser so much on my plate at home why
did I come here
I should have dealt with my things there
I I should have waited gone to next
year's
Retreat I said that's the selft talk in
the head you will May encounter it here
too as you walk from here to there you
will encounter the selft talk in the
head so how do you get out of the selft
talk in the
head
one you need to know that that self talk
in the head if you don't know it selft
talk in the head you become the selft
talk in your head you become the voice
in your head you don't know it you are
it so you have
to the the vital step and I cannot tell
you how to do
that that minimum of awareness needs to
be there where you
know that there's selft talk happening
in my head and it's telling you some
kind of story could be the briefest of
stories like I shouldn't have come here
or I don't fit in here all these people
are too spiritual for
me
[Music]
or I'm so spiritual these people are not
spiritual at
all it's all little stories in the head
every every even every fragment of selft
talk is a little story in the head that
goes
around and then you look at reality
through the length of the little story
it's not just one story of course it
comes another one into another and and
some little some stories are not little
they may be big
stories about
yourself and your life and what's gone
wrong with it or what's gone right with
it even that's a story
more pleasant than if it's gone
wrong so you you need to know when the
self selft talk happens in the
head The Knowing is not part of The
selft Talk The Knowing is just an
awareness that there is selft talk the
moment there is an awareness that there
is selft talk the possibility of Freedom
From The selft Talk opens up most of the
time there is a voice in your head that
comments and has opinions and viewpoints
and
interpretations about what's going on in
your life I call that the voice in the
head for most humans that is completely
involuntary they don't even know that
they have a voice in the head that never
stops
talking most of the
time silently in your head and at other
times it may even shout something out so
it it wants to be
heard and so if you walk in the street
you will find most people look fairly
sane they're not talking to themselves
it seems because they're not talking out
aloud but if you listened into
everybody's head you would be amazed of
how
noisy the inside of every human is
it's like a r you know these radio
stations where the the people talk in an
excited voice they go on and
on if you go to a foreign country and
you don't know what they're talking
about you might think this must be
extremely
important but if you can understand what
they are saying you realize it's it's
completely meaningless it's just
noise so a significant part of what
happens in your mind
the the larger part is actually just
Superfluous
noise there's thinking is a wonderful
ability a wonderful tool if used
rightly it is an instrument that
causes dysfunction and misery for
Millions on the planet unhappiness for
Millions on the planet if thinking is
not used but if you are used by thought
so when humans say I think in most cases
that's actually not true because they
have no control over their thinking it's
an compulsive and
involuntary and they are so identified
with these thought processes they don't
even know that they are in the grip of
their thought processes because
they are so identified they become their
thought processes so whatever comes into
your head you completely believe in it
and then you yeah that's how it is
whenever you
feel unhappiness this is a generic term
unhappiness in whatever form unhappiness
can arise as
irritation can arise as anger can arise
as
even boredom is a form of unhappiness
sadness um all kinds of states that
don't they don't feel Pleasant they
unhappiness and usually they attributed
to a life situation something that's
going on in your
life so for example waiting at the
airline counter and of course how often
things don't go well
there uh let's hope they don't drag you
out of the plane but that could that
could happen
too whenever you feel irritation arising
anger Rising upset in whatever form ask
yourself is this caused by the
situation or is it caused by what my
mind is telling me about the
situation and in 95% of
cases you will find that the mental
commentary that argues and complains
about something that's going on but
should not be going on but it is but
shouldn't be and the gap between what is
and what the mind says should be or
should not be that Gap is the rising of
unhappiness and
misery or is the Buddha called suffering
a powerful uh transformation can happen
when you and this this is one way of
approaching it which may be helpful to
you uh is
not to
desire
any thing within you to be different
from the way it is
now so that would
mean complete acceptance of whatever it
is that you experience at any given
moment at the moment there are these
energies in you but you don't really
want them so there is a there's a
conflict between what you want and what
you
have now if you approach it in a
different way instead of having what you
want you perhaps you want Stillness you
want peace you want that deeper sense of
aliveness perhaps that's the yearning
you want to bre fully
yourself and what what you have is you
perhaps you feel contraction in the body
you feel excessive mind activity you
feel an En
almost semi physical energy field
blocking you so you have the two you
have what you want and you have what you
have now as a practice I suggest
that you do away with a conflict between
what you have and what you want
and you want what you have
instead which means whatever your inner
reality or outer reality but we're
talking mainly about inner now whatever
your inner reality is right now as it's
always now of course not it's not a big
thing it's only the reality
now accept it it totally this is this is
what is and so bring that acceptance is
a strange thing when you really can say
well that's what is you might as well
accept it because it it is a reality of
this
moment so if you bring that exception no
matter even if it feels not pleasant if
it might be a contraction in the body or
my mind is just so active Okay let my
mind be active bringing bring the
allowing to it and that the strange
thing happens you may find when you do
it you you already be have a little bit
of space around the condition that you
dislike but now you accept and so you
accept the condition that you previously
disliked but now you say well that's
what is and so I allow it to be and what
you then can sense if you're inside of
you a little bit of space around the
condition to not much at first just a
little bit so let's say you have a
contraction here and say that's what
is and this
acceptance brings space so here is a and
then he have a little bit of that's what
is and
then it may grow a little bit the space
around
it and then you
[Music]
find you become more interested in that
little space around it than in the
condition so you give more ATT attention
to that the spaciousness that around
that comes with the
acceptance of what is and you can sense
that space a bit more and then it what
I'm saying is not literally true but I'm
just saying it grows it seems to grow
and then there a bit more the still
condition is still the same but it has
receded somewhat it's no longer the
center of your attention you the you
have more aware of the space you become
the space fight I had a very extremely
painful relationship with
myself I couldn't live with myself
anymore and so
I somehow said that's it I can't live
with it anymore that's it but that was
so
total that I no longer
sustained fueled the self through
thought I didn't know anything about it
it just
happened so the mindmade image
dissolved the self that I couldn't live
with that was
so heavy
dissolved and what was left was
simply
I so the eye shifted from words before
when I said I I was referring to myself
the UN happy dense eye the story based
eye that dissolved and then the
true
I emerged had always been
there
presence I
am nothing in particular anymore a
simple sense of presence or
beingness and for the first time I could
walk
and be without having a relationship
with
myself and that there is
something so precious in
that eye of
presence
[Music]
so it's beyond words you could say it's
like a diamond it's something extremely
very very precious that's why perhaps
Buddhism sometimes has the image of
diamond but this is not
comparative it's not a sense
of that deepest self not the mindmade
self is so precious that it
has it knows itself to be that in a non
dualistic way without needing to compare
itself to others it has nothing to do
with a form or any mind
form so as presence
arises you don't
need self-esteem anymore you don't
depend on that
anymore because what dissolves is the
mindmade entity with which you have a
relationship
and it's so self-esteem is an
intermediate thing that for a little
while makes your life more pleasant it's
fine and
then after a while you see the
unsatisfactory nature even of that
because you cannot uphold
continuous self-esteem it's hard
work all these
affirmations and then things come into
your life that tell you the
opposite inevitably sooner or
later so then suddenly you don't love
yourself anymore nor do you hate
yourself because there's no self to love
they're simply the state of this which
is love it emanates
in
presence all this what I sometimes call
unnecessary
baggage that people
manufacture mentally and
emotionally or that unnecessary baggage
that really is a there's a heaviness to
it that they carry
around doesn't arise anymore and there
the simple this is what is I can either
do this or I can do that I can deal with
it now I can put it aside this no story
but this is frustrating to the ego
because when there's no longer any story
where you oppose the
other where you make yourself feel
superior to the other then there's no
food for the ego
[Music]
anymore but there's an incredible
lightness and the lightness of being
comes and the heaviness goes out of
situations that really that's what the
ego
is a heavy
me and even when
it attempts to make itself
Superior what it doesn't
recognize is that all these are really
forms of suffering the ego doesn't even
recognize suffer suffering is suffering
it doesn't realize that when you get
angry or irritated about somebody else's
behavior and bring up a big story about
it you are actually in a state of
suffering if you were able to have
attention into in your body you would
notice that your body is suffering
because those things affect the smooth
harmonious working of the energy
field that goes through the body so an
angry thought has an effect on the
body small irritation or has an effect
and the body doesn't really like
it but the ego the egoic itself is not
in touch with the body so it and it
mistakes suffering for something
good anger can really get into
[Music]
this so you can look at your own life
and see where you are manufacturing
unnecessary stories both in small
situations and in bigger life
situations and in situations to do with
uh relatives family
members
Partners ex Partners a wonderful source
of egoic
stories and talk about your ex-husband
or wife for hours either to somebody
else if they're ready to listen or in
your own
mind or you had a confrontation or an
exchange with some somebody yesterday
and you can go on continue that in your
mind and say so many hurtful things to
the other person that unfortunately you
couldn't think of in the
situation but you can relive it now and
it's almost as good as the real
[Laughter]
thing so in that fantasy world of the
mind you can be right again and again
and the other person can be wrong again
and again how
[Music]
[Laughter]
wonderful these things are not all this
is what we call unconscious so people
don't
know what they are doing that's for them
that is their reality maybe you
lost possessions money whatever and and
the question
is do we resign ourselves to the loss or
should we take action to bring new forms
of abundance into being
[Music]
well you can
do you can resign your it's not a
question of either
or whether or not you create more of the
same whatever it is if you lost a house
whether you work to have have another
house or if you lost Investments whether
you work hard to create the same
again or whether you no longer are
interested in doing that in any case
resigning yourself to the
loss applies in any
case if you don't do that then you
suffer and then you build up negativity
and then you all your the action you
take is then based on negative reaction
and you can work very hard and perhaps
you'll recreate the same
abundance but it's not
pleasant so acceptance of what is always
comes first and then you're free to go
on from there acceptance of
loss that's what is nothing is permanent
in this world it consists of gain and
loss
sooner or later you have to let
go acceptance comes first and then
there's a choice if you enjoy the
creation of abundant forms whatever you
do why not carry on doing it and very
quickly you will probably create the
same abundance if you don't enjoy the
doing if the doing is only a means to an
end because you you need the money you
want to have the psychological security
of money you still haven't learned that
it doesn't really
work then you just go through the
same cycle
again and you won't be
happy you'll be compulsively working
hard trying to get your money
back
so it's a question
of Step One is acceptance of what is
because it is step two
is you listen
within and see what it
is that wants to be done I'm in the
investment world so I'm always faced
with um a lot of
resistance because it's not conducive to
good business to spend too much time
being too
soft and I was wondering if you can
comment a little bit on how can I help
the patients and also help uh the people
who are in the business side of things
do not
compromise on what you feel you are
called upon to
do with other human beings and don't so
don't compromise and say okay I'll just
have to drop this and just treat them to
like everybody else but see if you can
still function from within the system
and do what you feel you need to
do and if you can't
again it's it's a question of doing it
in a new way doing creating something
that makes it possible for you to work
on both levels on the outer level and
the inner level with human beings thank
you that's a very again this question
comes up very often for many people in
different ways and many of you may
find as because you represent the
arising and The Awakening Consciousness
many of you will find that the existing
structures within which you
work are not able to C carry the new
Consciousness anymore it's Jesus used
this funny expression
uh new wine in Old
bottles uh because apparently at the
time the bottles were not glass bottles
they were kind of leather bottles and if
you for some reason if you put a new one
in they would probably burst so what
that means is the the many of the
existing
structures social structure that also
applies to economic structures the
structures in medical medicine
Psychiatry psychology C
education school
system University system many of those
structures they were created by not by
the awakened Consciousness they they
were all they've all been around for a
long time and they evolved out of the
egoic
Consciousness so many of the structors
are the product of
unenlightened states of
Consciousness they reflect the unlight
UN awakened States Of
Consciousness
so many of you will find uh it
necessary to step out of sometimes as I
said they can May in certain cases they
can be changed from within if there are
enough people within who want to change
it but many structures are too rigid for
change so it is up to you to create new
structures that reflect your and come
together perhaps with others who are
also Awakening so that the new
structures will reflect your State of
Consciousness I haven't mentioned being
in the body for a
[Music]
while so let's feel it now that you are
actually feel the energy field of your
as you sit there and I I sit here we
feel a certain aliveness pervading the
body it's very
simple
but some attention has to go there
otherwise you can't feel
anything which means you have to take
some attention away from
thinking if you're full in thought you
can't feel your body at all you not
don't feel alive
anymore just
abstractions so the beautiful thing is
it's not only that your body
loves being acknowledged and getting
your
attention it's it's a very healing thing
to
do and most
importantly
it slows down your thinking considerably
if it doesn't even stop it completely
because you have to if you have your
attention here you can't have it
there and this be the embodied State
it's quite nice what you're feeling is
not ultimately the physical body it's
already halfway beyond the physical
body she
Life
Energy and I call that it's halfway
between form and
formlessness it's a bridge G is the
bridge between the the formless
dimension and the
form so it's wonderful to be to sense
that and it can
be you can do it anywhere when you're
there's enough room you don't need to
focus on externals 100% have some
attention in the body as we sit
here boredom disappears for example when
you have a tension in the body you're
not bored you actually enjoy being
feeling
alive and that it's can serve as an
anchor for staying present and that can
be one way of
looking around at the
world
without unnecessary mental
labeling as Clarity of
perception and looking at the situations
that arise in that Clarity of
perception and from that Clarity of
perception you know what you need to do
or what needs doing in that situation
it's a higher
intelligence that you contact via the
body a higher intelligence than the
acquired knowledge of the human
mind and then you know what to do it it
acts it tells you have an inside or
spontaneous
doing or if there's nothing to do it
being is enough it's you can enjoy just
being
sleepless nights are wonderful
opportunity for going into the
body oh I can't sleep I wish I could
sleep why don't you do something useful
go into the
body and then you lie
there and feel the the
aliveness oh I wish I I hope I won't go
to sleep too soon because it's so
nice
and before you know it you've gone to
sleep
perhaps and then you wake up in the
morning perhaps you still feel a
lingering sensation there in the body
and if you
don't as you wake up put your attention
into the body first before you start
thinking about the
day for just a couple of minutes 3
minutes to
is it's a good start of the
day to feel alive it can't be a bad
start to the day taking responsibility
for your life is taking responsibility
for how you perform your actions what
you
do and if most of your actions are means
to an end your whole life is of low
quality it lacks presence
and you always looking out for the next
moment which you think is going to be
better when it comes is unfortunately
only the present moment which isn't
never good
enough that's low quality
life your the quality of your life the
way in which I use the term is deeper
than the conventional use of the term or
it's good to have the term at all
quality of life because it implies
that what
determines the the value of your life is
not quantity it's not how much you
consume how many things you
own or whatever how many
people you control in your job or your
whatever it's not quantity that
determines the the value of your life
it's quality so in the conventional term
I'm glad that this term exists it
means how you en whether you enjoy
whether you can go
to have quality time with another human
being which means attention quality
activities where you're not just working
all the time but doing other things they
have the quality of life for
cities every year they have a list I
don't remember who publishes it or how
they exactly they determine it but it's
intemp to
determine how pleasant it is to live or
how unpleasant it is to live in a
particular City many
factors contribute to that so that's a
good thing but the way in which IU
quality goes even beyond that or it's it
is connect it somehow but it goes It
goes
deeper you can live in a city that's
very low on the life quality
list and lead a life of the highest
quality which
means as you do what you
do you giving it
full
attention knowing that yes and you I'm
doing this
because that I need to get there and
there you know what the end is that you
want to achieve but your primary concern
is the
doing the smallest thing and then your
life is of high quality every action has
a certain aliveness and presence to it
it's not stressed it's it's not done
with reluctance it's not done with
impatience it's not done with irritation
all this can can't you see how that
lowers the quality of your life all
those
things but it's so
normal but you can do the same thing why
bring all that to the action the
irritation the stress the
dislike the
impatience the complaining
why what purpose does it it has no real
purpose except it strengthens your false
sense of self how do we deal with a
collective problem with through presence
or through
reactivity and if we deal through by the
way when you deal with something through
presence it means there's wisdom this is
another important
word wisdom
arises out of
presence wisdom is different from
intelligence intelligence is the ability
to use the conceptual
mind that has its purpose it's fine but
there is something deeper and more
important in every potentially in every
human being and it's not intelligence
it's wisdom wisdom is the this faculty
that arises out of presence and then you
can deal with City situations truly
intelligently rather than reactively and
you do not make the situation worse by
your reaction to the
situation um so you need wisdom what the
world needs is not more
intelligence very soon AI is become
probably becoming more intelligent than
humans and and the human challenge is to
access the dimension where wisdom
arises that's
com computers don't have that they can
be very good at thinking
probably they're making incredible
advances but not wisdom wisdom so we
need to as as we are being almost
replaced by
artificial
thinkers uh this
coincides with the transition of human
beings to a higher state of
consciousness than thinking where of
course they can still think but they are
not trapped in
thinking and so it's terribly
important and again coming back for a
moment to that situation um Collective
situation
there's Collective
challenge we had the
uh um pandemic situation as a huge
Collective
challenge was there wisdom in the way in
which
we reacted to their
challenge not very much uh there was a
lot of fear there was a lot of panic a
lot of
anger uh
and many measures were
taken not necessarily seeing all the
possible repercussions of measures that
were taken that would still play
themselves out in the next few years we
don't need to go into uh details but the
question is always do you create more
suffering by your reaction to a
situation than is contained in the
situation itself that's lack of wisdom
does
that and lack of wisdom means lack of
presence or awareness whatever word you
want to use if you're unable to enjoy
what you're
doing then it's time to move to another
job but you have to look to see whether
your inability to enjoy the job you're
doing
now has something to do with the
particular job doing or has more to
do with with your inability to enjoy the
present
moment in which case the next object you
find you will also not
enjoy so if you can't enjoy your
job either one of these is true either
there is something for you to change
there's something inherently not right
anymore with this particular job does no
longer corresponds to what
to who you are or your State of
Consciousness
or you cannot enjoy your job because you
haven't learned
yet to be present enough to enjoy what
you are doing now and you always
think oh the next one is going to be
much
[Music]
better and if you don't know which one
it is of those two
you may have to get another job and then
see if you can enjoy that
one many jobs that the mind tells you
cannot be
enjoyed actually can be
enjoyed also the mind telling you if you
enjoy this job that you do you really
don't want this job to be permanent and
if the mind tells you no if I enjoy this
job I'll be stuck with it for the rest
of my my life and I don't want to be
stuck with it let's say you you you got
a you got a job
working
[Music]
uh working in a diner as a waiter or
waitress but you really want to get your
job as an actress or you really want to
be a writer you really want to
be uh whatever you want to be as
Senator
uh successor of Donald Trump whatever
your mind
says and so the mind says like I'm not
going to enjoy this job because I really
want to be somewhere else and if I enjoy
it then I'll really be
stuck but you may find that the opposite
is the case if you it it is freeing to
enjoy what you are doing even if it's
not something that you would want to do
for the rest of your life all you have
to do is enjoy the present
moment your energy field then
shifts and when this energy field energy
field shifts you become open to life
only if you no longer resist life you
cannot be open to
life the greater Consciousness coming
through you if you resist life and you
resist life if
you resist or resent the present moment
that's where life is so the shift
happens you need to be in the state of
alignment with the present moment no
matter what activity you are doing in
the present moment and if you absolutely
cannot be in alignment with the present
moment you need to walk out it's already
a wonderful thing that you are able
to uh sense the Stillness which is of
course the temporary sensation of
thinking that's really what Stillness is
so a momentary Gap whether it's a few
seconds or a few minutes in the Stream
of thinking but no loss of
consciousness but rather one could
almost say an intensification of
Consciousness you're very alert but
still is that what you experience yes
that is what now the the rest is the the
mind comes in again and is asking
questions about it and it might say as
it does in your case which is not
uncommon the mind
says is that all there is there must be
more I I can't quite uh feel what some
other people talk about um that's
unnecessary to go there and uh try to
figure out mentally or from somebody
else to say that there is more you
should um let go of uh that it's really
is connected to the desire of the mind
to understand the Stillness that's
that's often part of that and you cannot
understand it I don't understand it
uh understanding can arise out of the
Stillness that is true the deeper
understanding of certain things arise
out out of the Stillness but the
Stillness
itself you cannot understand uh and
that's very reason why Jesus described
the this inner peace as I think it was
Jesus or was it St Paul I don't remember
the peace that passes all
understanding this peace which is the
inner PE which is stillness you cannot
it passes all understanding you cannot
understand it
understanding involves Concepts and
Concepts is thought so the Stillness you
cannot you cannot
understand um in fact it is the the
Stillness uh
comes when you
relinquish the desire to
understand I understand yourself or
understand the world when you relinquish
the desire to understand and then the
Stillness is immediately there asking is
the ability to ask is
wonderful um please thank you the um
because if if you're truly asking there
is a you there's a space of
openness if you're truly asking you you
voluntarily enter the state of not
knowing so and this is a one wonderful
ability to ask whatever it is so that
you be become a space you can ask a
person something you can
ask the universe something and but there
needs to be the receptivity if you you
can ask any kinds of questions but the
question needs to
be the question needs to come out of the
spaciousness of which is there when you
truly ask there many people who ask ask
questions and there's not the openness
to receive the answer and that is not
true
asking but to put yourself in this
basically it's connected with the state
of not
knowing so that you can and that's the
part of
the state of awareness is that you an
aspect of it is that you're in that
state of not knowing concept naturally
so there is
a there's nothing more beautiful than
asking a question and uh if it's
directed to other human beings
then people love to be asked through
questions and they can feel whether
there is an openness there or whether
you have certain
expectations as far as the answer is
concerned so that in itself is a
spiritual great spiritual practice to
ask how can we overcome or eliminate
stress and suffering and anxiety in our
lives when it seems to be crippling us
unhappiness is another word you could
use it's a generic term for any form of
negativity inside yourself unhappiness
suffering what so you begin to realize
that most of that arises from a mental
narrative about a situation or or about
your circumstances but not from the
circumstances
themselves and and then you can begin to
practice every time you feel upset is
arising some form of neg anger is
arising some form of
negativity uh blaming people in
situations and saying this shouldn't be
happening or something is not happening
but it should be happening or they
should do this or they shouldn't do
all kinds of narratives in your mind so
you spiritually Awakening is you're
beginning to be aware of what your mind
is
saying uh the the stor that you're
telling yourself about
situations but also the stories you're
telling yourself about what you call
your
life so because people there are
millions of people in this world who
lived with a very painful sense of
identity they they perceive their life
as a burden so they live with this
heaviness and they don't
realize what they this heaviness that
they call my life is actually a
narrative that they tell themselves and
they say that's me all the things that
have happened to me the Dreadful things
in the past that people did to me or
circumstances did to me or maybe even
the bad things that I did so you get a
very heavy identity buils up and that
becomes your sense of self and people
don't realize it's a it's a story you're
continuously telling yourself in your
mind but you're are so identified with a
story that you don't exist you outside
of the story it is true that negative
thinking can be very
addictive I from my point of view it is
not caused by the chemical that's
generated in the brain or the I do not
deny that the chemicals in the body very
often reflect certain things that happen
on the mental emotional level but what
comes first the chicken or the egg so if
you if you become very angry of course
there are certain chemicals that are
released in the body and if you become
peaceful then they go the addiction is
not in the chemical other I don't deny
that there is a CH chemical component to
emotional states but it is the addiction
to negative
thinking and the addiction to negative
thinking is usually connected to the
pain body which is the emotional field
that Fields fed
fueled by the negative thinking so it
who addiction means it feels on some
level it feels good if you're addicted
to something on some level it feels good
if you're addicted to alcohol the
drinking feels good while you drink not
afterwards but while you drink so if
you're
addicted well who
feel to whom does it feel good not to
you not to the physical body because the
physical body suffers through it but to
the pain body this emotion loves to get
more of the same energy by generating
further negative thinking in your mind
and it feeds on it because it doesn't
get enough food through the drama in
your relationship so the awareness has
to come in so that you break the
link
between your pain body and your thought
processes that is the key is to sever
the link between your thought processes
and the pain body in order to sa the
link between those there needs to be
enough awareness presence only the
presence can s the link the presence
comes in and so you you no longer the
emotion is no longer controlling your
thought
activity that's the
key and that's the beginning of the end
of that vicious circle that otherwise
will take over your life
so what is
needed is for you to be there in the
moments these thoughts occur or
immediately after and then immediately
look at the thought and say that's again
and do not believe it and again it comes
back
to the state of
connectedness with being it's only from
that state of
connectedness with a deeper dimension of
who you are from
there it becomes easier to forgive
because forgive means there was
something that was done on the level of
form by one life form to to you perhaps
another life form pain was
inflicted or whatever it may be treat uh
whatever the transgression
is
and
it's only from there that you can see
the relative nature of what was done
because you're in touch with a space
within you that was
never hurt by that that dimension in you
is beyond what can be
injured it's only the form can be
injured the psychological form somebody
might have insulted you deeply the
psychological form of who who you are
can be can feel
pain or the physical form of who you are
can feel
pain and somebody inflicted that out of
unconsciousness then recognizing the
first step in uh forgiving is to
recognize that this was an act of
unconsciousness on and you do not equate
what the this person did with who that
person
is and it's only from the place of
connectedness with being that you can
say no longer hold a grievance about
that because you in touch with that
inside you that is beyond what can be
injured if you're not in touch with that
space then you're still it's hard to
forgive not to forgiving means not not
to Harbor grievance or resentment or any
negative feeling about
it and really that's only possible when
you are connected with the formless in
yourself instead of giving more
attention to your
thinking you just take your attention
into the inner energy field of the body
and suddenly you feel the aliveness that
pervades the entire body
and so you have taken Consciousness away
from the
mind and put it in here and you can't
think that much anymore you can't feel
the body and be engaged in a lot of
thinking and if you really fully
experience the liveness in the inner
body the Mind
stops and so that is a becomes an anchor
for awareness an anchor for or
presence even if you just even if you
cannot feel the entire body it would be
enough to just go into your hands with
your
attention just take Consciousness into
your hands and feel the aliveness in
your hands that
alone can take attention away from
useless thinking and you continue to
feel because that is part of
experiencing the present moment which
actually feels quite good it feels good
to be
alive that's an amazing realization I
would love to hear your thoughts on your
definition of the Law of Attraction but
also maybe the three habits that you see
people doing the most that hurt them
from attracting effortlessly using the
Law of Attraction right well the main uh
mistake perhaps that people make is uh
not coming from a place of fullness but
coming from a place of
neediness and uh and putting too much
attention on on what
is the undesirable conditions that they
want to get rid of but but but mentally
almost continuously focusing on the
undesirable condition like not enough
money for example which is the problem
for many people uh so so let's use let's
use money for the example then the Law
of Attraction with money how could we
attract more wealth or financial
abundance in our life using the Law of
Attraction yeah well first of all is the
acknowledgment of abundance that is
already here and now and not and not
focusing on the lack of abundance that
is here now which you could find by
thinking about it but to actually focus
on where is the abundance that I can
find here and now and that is all around
you it is in nature when you look at the
the abundance of nature the Abundant the
multiplicity of life forms The Wonder of
nature uh the abundance of even even or
let's say you're in a city uh you can
look at uh appreciate all the things
that you see uh around you you don't
need to necessarily own it or buy it
just appreciate it and so this first the
appreciation of the goodness of life
that is always all around you even if
you have no money there's still the
goodness of life is all around you you
see it all around you the
sunshine I mean the sun is the
ultimate symbol of abundance because it
gives energy of itself almost etern I
mean eventually the sun will die but as
far as we are concerned it's virtually
Eternal it it pours out energy
continuously and this uh at some point
we will realize that even on the level
of energy the universe is infinitely
abundant so we we will no longer
need things that we're using now fossil
Fus and those things we have access to
other forms of energy that are more
helpful but right the abundance the
abundance is all around you let's say
you walk your past in the city you're
walking past a slower shop and you look
at wow such beauty
appreciation even to seeing a beautiful
man or woman or nice or or even a
beautiful car oh I loves it not why
don't I have that car why does he have
that car it's all egoic
much narratives that make you unhappy to
appreciate no nature of course is very
powerful and then you to
appreciate the aliveness in your body
that you're breathing and you can
actually feel that the the your body but
many people can't feel that I call it
the inner body awareness you feel that
your that every cell of your body is
pervaded with a sense of aliveness
energy and you can feel that
that is abundance so there's abundance
of Life all around you there's there's
you can feel the life within you also
and so we could some people call it
gratitude I call it more appreciation
the appreciation of the abundance of
life that is always around you that's a
wonderful starting point being is the
one thing of course it's not a thing we
just using words is there one thing that
you can be absolutely sure about the
only thing that is beyond
doubt in your
life the only thing whose reality is
beyond
doubt everything
else could be a dream or an
illusion whatever you
perceive could be a dream dream an
illusion you don't know that it's not a
dream or an
illusion because when this meditation
comes to an end then it evaporates into
the so-called
past and everything that happens
quickly dissolves dissolves
dissolves the same way that a dream
comes to an end when you wake
up except that this dream seems to go on
and on replaced by another and
another if it is a
dream but something what is it then that
cannot be
doubted that there is
a
Consciousness in which if it is a
dream whether it's a reality of dream
just matter in which it arises in which
it is known the light in which it
appears so your
presence cannot be doubted whatever
happens in that presence can be
doubted but for it to happen there must
be a presence and of course I said your
presence it's not your presence it's the
one universal presence
Consciousness I particularly
welcome those of
you
who are getting tired of their
personality that cumber some that wait
you carry
around and creates the same old stuff
again and
[Music]
again it's a good point to
reach to become tired of
yourself
that is sometimes
misperceived and then you think you're
tired of the world you're tired of
living you're tired of that's a
misperception what you're really tired
of is the
self and the world that it creates seem
to create out
there with the same old conflict the
same old
problems or different problems but
basically the same if you deep
[Music]
down the same old thoughts in your head
again and again the same
complaints oh dear saw the spiritual
path
there are many practices you can
use in order
to access the dimension of presence
which is the spiritual
Dimension but the most direct
practice that
immediately accesses that
Dimension we could call
that
[Music]
surrender what is
that
[Music]
it is to offer no resistance or
opposition to whatever arises in the
present moment whatever happens whatever
arises whatever people say or
do
to become one
with the
isness of the present moment the present
moment always already is the way it
is there's no doubt about that whatever
Form This Moment takes it is as it
is and if internally then you give up
opposing which is the normal State
associated with dense person
personalities instead of opposing
internally what
is getting upset getting angry arguing
with what is either just in your head or
out
aloud telling people what they should
have done or should be doing but are not
doing what it should be like but it
isn't like what I should be doing what
I'm not doing I should be whatever the
whatever form
the opposition
takes and I
mentioned a few minutes
ago those of you who are getting tired
of the old personality and of course
this is part of the old personality the
way in which it interacts
with people and events and
places it's not usually
Pleasant there's always some resistance
always something not good enough always
something missing Here and
Now wherever you go the structure stays
with you goes with
you so you recognize that that's
an important part
[Music]
of the false self that lives
through opposition to what is it
strengthens itself through that sense of
Separation separating itself from what's
going
on condemning it judging
it and
people and then you
realize what happens if I just accept
that whatever arises is in the present
moment say oh that's what
[Music]
is you can still take action but
Foundation is acceptance
surrender and then immediately the false
self can't really operate
anymore and something else comes in
which is Essence which is awareness
which is consciousness
itself so the most fundamental spiritual
practice
is
surrender so that
internally you're one with what
is and in immediately you are a
spiritual
[Music]
Master because that's all a master
master does not necessarily have more
knowledge than you you may have much
more knowledge than a spiritual
Master but the master lives in alignment
with the isness of the present moment
that's
all and that's where the power
arises because when you're aligned with
the is
that inner spaciousness opens up Essence
is
there and that is the power that then
moves through you and can become a
thought it can express itself in form
through a a thought an
action a
movement some something you do or make
in many ways or just as an
emanation
that is true power when you feel the
need arise to be defensive about
anything know that you have identified
yourself with an
illusion it is not danger that comes
when defenses are laid down it is safety
it is peace peace it is
joy and it is
God
so when you feel the need arise to be
defensive about anything know that you
have identified yourself with an
illusion when you become defensive about
something
then it it will be some something that
is conceptual you as a concept or some
concept you hold that you need to defend
because you have identified with it so
you are defending your sense of self
your fictitious sense of
self that means you're defending an
illusion when you don't defend because
the truth of who you are does not mean
to be
defended so to let go of the
defenses can be a way
of
[Music]
accessing the deeper dimension of who
you
are and of course takes you beyond ego
because the defensiveness is ego ego is
conceptual identity in my
defenselessness my safety
lies you're safe
already so you don't need to defend
anything nothing real can be
threatened nothing unreal
exists herein lies the peace of
God here in meaning knowing
this lies the peace of
God I'll just let it be at that I not
going to interpret those lines I believe
it's a they're most powerful if you just
let them sink in there's an innate human
feeling you see something and it has a
lot of attention and it's shiny and it's
whatever and that everyone wants to get
in but basically you're saying if you
would take that breath if you would just
say I don't want in on this that
eventually you can actually you can
almost pull other people out of it too
by your own behavior yes because this
isn't just about you yes also not to
feed
uh other if other people post negative
things about you in many many cases
non-reaction is the best thing instead
of feeding it that's a lesson I need to
learn I will try to take that one with
me that applies both offline and online
in your personal life too often it's
just well I believe Jesus was talking
about non-reaction when he talked about
turning the other cheek I don't think
it's to be taken
literally but it means when someone
somebody attacks you not not physically
it's an analogy he uses it's a parable
uh to on the other seek is means to just
be free of
reaction and that uh that uh very
quickly deflates even the the other
person's ego it doesn't the ego needs
the reaction it needs the
reactivity so that's a powerful thing
but how do you avoid then just becoming
a pushover within that well in some
situations something needs to be said
but even then that can come from you
could
say let's especially if you're with
somebody that kind of behavior is
unacceptable you can say that um in a
conscious way rather than in a
destructive and aggressive way you can
one can actually be very firm and
conscious uh or when you say no to
somebody uh it doesn't have to be
aggressive uh it's just going a a clear
I call it a high quality
no uh somebody says can you lend me
again I've uh uh $2,000 I need I know I
still owe you 20,000 but I need some
more and then and then not to make the
other into an enemy just no I'm sorry
can't do it anymore it's a high quality
no that's a you're present while you say
it and then you can set boundaries if
necessary so in some cases uh something
needs to be said we need to do something
but in many other cases complete
non-reactivity can be very very powerful
Whenever there is a situation let's say
at work or like an emotional
relationship one one side of my mind is
like this not going to work out blah
blah and the other side is this is going
to work out no yes no and all day long
seriously I'm doing something and in my
mind they're going to lay you off no
they're not going to lay her off no
they're going to lay her off no
no it seriously comes to a point of
losing my mind
and sometimes but sometimes I know it so
strongly so I can calm myself down so I
just wanted to ask you how can I know
what's the right
answer
the I mean what's the voice of intuition
like how do I know the voice of
intuition instead of this
fighting okay okay well I believe uh
many people recognize your question
in it's a pattern in the human mind and
perhaps in you it's stronger than in
some who know
but it's in in many people's
minds
uh so it's of course the the answer is
in and this is your
challenge is not trying to figure out
which of these voices is the right one
that's not
it it's to discover within yourself
that space that is not the voice that
space of
awareness so that can only you can only
practice that while it
happens there's that
voice and then there's the other
voice and who
is aware of these voices you don't need
to answer that question I'm just putting
it out don't answer it because there's
no answer answer there's only a direct
realization of it within yourself
there's no external answer because if
you give an answer that's another
voice so this is a question that you
should not answer in words so I'm asking
again who is it in you who or
what there's something in you that is
aware of these different conflicting
voices there is an awareness otherwise
you wouldn't know that there is a
voice now the voice is a these are
thought
formations these are energy every
thought is an energy field and each
thought formation wants
to draw your attention suck it up into
itself come here and the other one says
no come here these are like little this
may sound a little spooky but it it's
not
spooky uh what you can regard a
thought almost as an as an entity not
not a physical entity but as a as an
energetic entity and that lives there it
it has a it has a lifespan and some
thoughts uh persist for a long time and
certain thought patterns are also
entities that can shift take on one form
and then another form and another form
so you have every thought is a little
entity or energy
field it wants to it wants
your identification with it it wants to
draw your all your attention in because
the more attention get get drawn in the
more it grows it wants to grow it wants
to like everything wants to it wants
doesn't want to disappear so it's for
you to know when this
happens who am I you
are are you this voice or that voice no
you are aware of the voice all these
voices and that is the place where you
go so that from that place of aware
presence the voices are no longer
disturbing you you recognize them as
only a voice this is not important
important whether you go this way or
that way or whether something is going
to work out or something is not going to
work out you don't know that your
responsibility is to be present which
means to disidentify from the voices can
we trust our
feelings now often you hear people say
trust your
feelings I would suggest
however that that's not necessarily
true acknowledge your
feelings yes be there as the observing
presence for your feelings yes be aware
of your feelings except that they are
there trust which
means to take them to be the truth or
the truth for you
or using them as a guide to correct or
skillful action that may be doubtful
because it depends where these feelings
arise in
you a little anecdote from my life to
illustrate
that when I lived in England in the
country in that alter native town
glastenbury for 3
years I lived in a
cottage
and once a month I would travel to
London or other cities in my beloved
Russian made Lada
car and to do a
workshop and usually a weekend Workshop
uh
called things
like transcending
time or be here now nothing much has
changed except that the average number
of people I had was about
10 and since my income was not enough I
had to rent out a room upstairs in my
Cottage so I had
a over these three year three years a
few
people was a second room but alas
anyway the room became vacant I
advertised in the local local paper
several people came to apply and and
finally chose a young uh woman who had
just been offered a job in that town she
came she moved
in and after the first night night in
her room she came down for breakfast
into the kitchen which was a sad kitchen
and she said I can't stay
here what's wrong I just I just it's
just a feeling and I always listen to my
feelings I just I just can't stay it
there's something not
right I was very
nervous and uh I said okay that's
fine and that she found that very
disconcerting because she had a expected
a more conventional
response which would have been what I've
interviewed all these people I've chosen
you and now what you're doing this to me
I'm you're you're not getting your rent
money back that you paid in advance but
I said okay I'll give you your money
back it's fine so she was even more
confused after
that and I said he said I'll spend one
more night or two more nights she spent
the second night and then in the morning
she
said uh no I think I'll
stay I have a different feeling
now and I said oh that's fine that's
good and again she was a little
disconcerted because the conventional
response would have
been which I did do I just put another
ad in the paper
yeah and now you're telling me
this this this is how to make the
conventional responses are how to make
life complicated for yourself and others
but it's normal it's how the ego
responds and so whenever somebody does
not respond in that way life becomes
simple but when life becomes simple
people who expect the conventional
responses become confused what this is a
weird
person and so she decided to stay and a
few weeks later when I got to know her
better she explained to me that that
first night she was in her
bedroom and she
said I found you so weird that I I
thought you might creep in in the middle
of the night and murder
me and later he
said living in the same house with you
is like living in a float tank
I think she learned a lot not so much
through me explaining things to her just
by being there
uh not that she didn't go through her
episodes
of neurotic reactivity which is quite
normal for most people but that's
fine uh so feelings now where did her
the initial feelings that she
experienced that she that she
then
uh believed that they were a correct
guide for action of course they were not
because they originated in
fear and they were also originated in a
misinterpretation of reality
which is so easy to do for the mind to
misinterpret another person to
misinterpret a situation you
misinterpret because you see it through
the conditioning of your
mind you see it through your
beliefs your prior experiences in
childhood you see it through even other
things that have conditioned your mind
maybe even scary movies about weird
people who don't say
much and then just when you're having a
shower they creep
in so the it is not therefore it's not
that easy often to to say where does
this feeling that I have
arise where does this feeling originate
how do I strike a healthy balance
between simply accepting life as it
unfolds and actively working towards and
striving towards goals destinations
aspirations well accepting life as it
unfolds of course is the foundation for
conscious and sane living accepting
whatever unfolds in the present moment
there is nothing
else that's the foundation does that
mean you
cannot have
goals you cannot have aspirations
wanting to achieve this do this do that
it's perfectly compatible with accepting
what is arising In This Moment one
difference between the unconscious state
which denies this moment and wants to
make it into a means to an end all the
time the difference then
is what is the motivation for your
doing If you deny this
moment can never embrace it honor it
appreciate it then the motivation for
your action is basically
dissatisfaction with what is
and the action is looked towards as a
possible way of
overcoming the discontent and the
dissatisfaction that you feel with the
present
moment and that's a very normal pattern
and that's in for many many people that
what is what motivates them they don't
feel good enough they don't
feel there some they feel there's
something fundamental missing in their
lives they don't feel recognized they
don't feel loved whatever and so they
try to find something achieve something
that will bring them that which they
feel is
missing they don't realize
that it's that is not going to work you
need to start
with the foundation for your life which
is this moment and go deeply into that
and
become okay with it friendly with it
realize it's the only thing there ever
is just this moment nothing ever exists
that's not this moment so you might as
well become friendly with it and
appreciate it and look around and see
how actually it's okay this moment is
actually
okay and if it's not okay you can still
say well that's what what is right now
if something goes wrong that's what
is and then things will come in that you
want to do you suddenly an idea comes or
you need to do something to make a
living and then out of that state of
becoming one with the isness of the
present moment something arises and once
that wants to take form in the world
that perhaps you want to create and then
you create it out of the joy of doing
instead of out of a feeling of lack that
you need something to make you complete
or
happy so the motivation changes from
neediness and
discontent
to joyful
doing it's not stressed anymore when
stress is a sign that you've lost the
present moment the next moment has
become more important than life itself
the greatest obstacle is
probably uh when meditation comes out of
a sense of lack or
neediness so you feel you you are
deprived of something be it money
or uh a relationship or a living
situation and you feel there's a great
lack in your life and you desperately
want this to
change and so you
perhaps uh use manifestation in a way
that is not likely to work when for
example you use affirmations such
as uh I want a better job I want a job
with a good income and a life situation
in a nice place and I want this and I
want
that um by making the these
statements uh you're actually by
implication saying that you don't have
it so you're also by saying that
you're uh uh there's a reverse side to
your statement I want and on the reverse
side of the statement I want there is
the statement I don't have and I
need and similar things please give me
if you you pray
to maybe God maybe you pray to Jesus
maybe you pray to Buddha they do that in
Buddhist countries maybe you pray to a
saint or whatever it is or you pray to
the universe and say please universe
please give me this please give me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works it could be accidentally who knows
but usually uh that greatly diminishes
your power of manifest ation because it
the man manifestation practice arises
out of a state of lack or neediness so
there's no powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that
encapsulates all the
books that have been written on
manifestation and will ever be written
on manifestation is just one simple
sentence it says when you pray for
something believe that
you that it has been given or that you
already have it and then then you will
receive it so the important thing is he
doesn't say believe that you will
receive it he says believe that you have
received it so there the secret is
hiding in that statement believe that
you have received it I will probably be
talking
poor most of the
time but there may
be quite a few gaps of Stillness in
between the
words as they are
now and these gaps are very
important I would even say more
important than the words if you become
conscious of these gaps of
Stillness in between
[Music]
words you notice the
gaps instead of just
impatiently being in your conceptual
mind and saying why is he talking so
slowly why hasn't he said anything sign
significant
yet if you are able to notice the gaps
give them
attention that is the arising of that
State of Consciousness that we call
presence it is a state
of aarm
Relaxed
alertness
Clarity a state in which the conceptual
mind has come to
rest and something else
arises thinking is most people's normal
state of when they are awake in
conventional
terms and when you become aware of these
gaps thinking
subsides and presence or we call it
awareness
arises thinking
subsides presence arises of course
thinking will come back but it has
briefly momentarily subsided something
else has
emerged
and that is what we call
presence it is a state of
one could say pure awareness or pure
Consciousness
so that is what sometimes
people hope to achieve in medit when
they actually do formal
meditations um meditation is a good
tool but it's not
enough it's not even for
everybody the most important thing is to
bring that state of clear alert
presence into everyday life there was a
long time when I had resentment towards
my father because my father was pretty
unconscious except very late in life had
a very strong ego and living with him as
a child uh was living with an unexploded
bomb that could go off at any moment got
these intense rages would
suddenly several times a week so I lived
in a constant state of kind of uh uh
background anxiety but is when is this
bomb going to explode again next and
then for a long time was in my 20s I had
a resentment towards him until I went to
this shift in Consciousness and I
suddenly
realized he he did what he had to do
there wasn't enough awareness in him to
act any different so he was at the mercy
of his own
conditioning um and once you see that
you no longer make it into an identity
for him uh and so you free him and
really perhaps this is the meaning of
forgiveness you can forgive yourself by
not making unconscious behavior in your
past into an identity for yourself or
for somebody else the normal thing to
happen is that this the connectedness
with your essence identity is lost very
easily in human
relationships because the mind is so
active and we live in a civilization
that provides Contin continuously
continuous and
incessant stimulus stimuli is the plural
continuous incessant stimuli for the
mind even more than even 30 years
ago 30 years ago it was just radio and
television and you would people would
sit there for
hours but nowadays you have countless
sources of stimulus for the for the mind
mind that draws you into
continuously thinking
about what's your next Facebook post
what's it going to be and you look at
the ones that are coming in all these
people are doing these fantastic
things and me I'm just sitting here and
then you have to pretend that you're
also doing fantastic
things and usually it involves taking a
nice
selfie
and then you project your self image
which has existed for a long long time
before in humans they have a they have
this part of ego is to have this image
of who I
am and but in in these div Facebook now
you have the opportunity to project that
image into the world and it'll reach
hundreds or thousands of
people all at
once and then you
you construct your life you there are
many people alive these days who without
knowing it they partly live for their
Facebook image and they're just looking
for the next thing that they can project
out into the world it's
narcissus you might remember the myth of
Narcissus the Greek ancient Greek myth
there was this young man who had never
seen himself before because they didn't
have mirrors at the time but one day he
to look into a little pool of
water and he saw himself and he realized
that he was extremely beautiful he said
oh that's
me and The Story Goes he fell in love
with
himself not in a good
[Music]
way not by becoming one with who he is
but but the separation happened this
myth shows the the beginning stage of
the egoic sense of self expressed as a
story the image that he of himself in a
pool is the mental image of the EG that
and stories are part of that image
that's me I'm me in my story so you have
the image of me and then oh so this guy
nissus he experienced that separation
uh and then I think something bad
happened to him but I don't remember
what so and then you have other div
things that continuously stimulate the
mind that almost designed for you not to
not to to to become still it's like the
civilization
has made a great effort to come up with
as many things as possible to prevent
people from becoming still and spacious
and had taking a moment
of looking at the sky and feeling the
inner spaciousness arise and becoming
aware of
the the leaves of the tree or the
branches and the wind blowing
and the noise of
water the simple thing becoming still
alert
sensing that Stillness within almost
everybody uh has in one way or another
being a victim of other people but in
some cases much much more so than in
others some element of having been
victim is probably present in
everybody's life
uh in other words you are surrounded by
unconscious humans and then unconscious
humans will inflict suffering on
themselves and others that's just how it
is when you are life in this on this
planet uh childhood particularly is a
place where many many children
experience um
abuse either minor forms of abuse
emotional abuse or they live in a very
toxic family environment and then of
course there are other children who
experience much more serious forms of
abuse and really
uh suffer and have these carry carry
with
them the the memory both mental and
emotional memory of uh what happened to
them in some cases the memory is
repressed because the the child uh the
emotions may be repressed the child
could not deal with them and they had to
repress them and then later the
possibility of remembering arises and
then you remember what happened to you
and how do you do it's the question what
do you do with what happened to you what
was done to you how do you deal with
what was done to you by other humans
whether it happened in childhood
or whether it happened later in
life whether it was a relatively minor
thing or whether it was a very serious
form of
abuse how do you how do you deal with
that
H now the the ego the human
ego is always looking for something to
add to its sent sense of identity it's
looking for a stronger sense of identity
because it always feels I'm not enough
so it's it's going it's trying to add
something that it can identify with so
add to its sense of
self and it very often happens that uh
the memory of of having been
abused is used by the
ego and is added to the ego
sense of self so that means you not only
remember what happened to you the memory
of what happened to you which
is a bundle of thoughts and emotion that
go with it the memory of what happened
to you is more than just a
memory there is
self-identification with the memory in
other words it's not not perceived as
just something that happened to you but
it becomes part of who you perceive to
be so I am a victim of that it's not
that this was done to me but I am a
victim of so it's the transition from
memory to
self that is the victim identity the ego
does that uh
because victim identity is a very
powerful form of identity a very
powerful form of
ego and particularly in cases where the
the ego is always
is does not find
sufficient things that it can identify
with in this world
because the most common form of
identification for example is with the
way you look
uh you look better than others so you
can identify with that if you look worse
in others of course that be could become
part of your victim identity because
you've been treated unfairly by life and
and life has made you look worse than
others that could become part of victim
identity Al that's not actually abuse
but it could all also be incorporated
into victim identity there are millions
of people in this world believe in
God and have no access have not found
within themselves access to the
spiritual
Dimension so we are
here in the case of some of you who are
perhaps new to this so to speak we are
here for for some of you to get perhaps
a glimpse of it as you sit here and
watch and
listen and I will endeavor to put you in
touch with
that
depth Within You Without which your life
is
frustrating and without which everything
you undertake every in ever and
every
activity ultimately becomes
frustrating and for
others we are here just to to deepen it
to provide a reminder on a conceptual
level but to deepen the dimension that
they already have access to
Within so that it can be sustained in
everyday
life one thing
is accessing the spiritual dimension in
a meditation setting like here and now
that's already a good thing if you are
able to do that when you sit
still become still
inside another thing is
to carry that with you so to speak so
that it is there when you lead your
life when you do
things talk to people
interact even when you think to have
that in the
background so we have the two steps one
could almost say first is you you
realize that within when you not being
disturbed like now hopefully you're not
being disturbed externally although you
may be disturbed as you sit here by your
mind that's quite possible who says what
is he talking
about because the mind doesn't
understand it the conceptual mind alone
is not sufficient to make this a
satisfying experience for you so for
this to be a
satisfying experience you need to
have at least a glimpse of what it is
that I am pointing to and a glimpse also
of that which underlies the
words and that's ultimately not in me
but ultimately you can only Glimpse that
in
you there's a Stillness behind the
words and as I speak Within
Myself And there can be a Stillness in
you as you listen to the
words and that would already be a
glimpse of the spiritual Dimension so
part of this is of course to be give
more attention to the present
moment because the more you think the
more future you
generate
and the more attention you give to the
present
moment the less thinking because to be
really present you don't think about it
you just are with it give it
attention I recommend the little things
of life to be more
attentive to all the little things that
make up every hour of every day
every minute every
hour and give them more
[Music]
attention walking steps one step at a
time objects that you're handling you're
all the time you're handling objects in
your life you're
always touching something putting
something here and
there
is everything that you handle just a
means to an end or are you able to just
appreciate the simple presence even of a
so-called inanimate
object contemplation also of all the
lovely things that make up your
environment part of your
environment for example if I were we're
sitting here
alone let's say I'm waiting for
everybody to
arrive I might be sitting here looking
of course at the
flow sense the Stillness and then
there's a glass table
here and then there's a glass of water
here and there's a clock and a bell and
tissues and they all reflect the light
in different ways
there's a little bit of a rainbow effect
in the glass of water
here and then the the lights are
reflected on the the belts almost like a
mirror and there's the clock ticking
away it's a beautiful scene sometimes
you go to an art gallery well not so
much with Modern Art but a very favor
favorite thing would be still life
artist and it took a while in art before
they discovered the the artists in the
history of art before they discovered
the seemingly insignificant things and
started to give attention to those
before that happened they were very much
interested in the huge things the Saints
or the Kings or the huge battle scene or
the the big they had to they painted
those things or the important
people or some dramatic thing volcanic
eruption or whatever
fire and then at some point they started
to discover the Beauty and the
[Music]
incredible sense of the quality that is
in the little things perhaps after these
more of these artists depicted
relatively in seemingly insignificant
things perhaps it motivated some people
to give more attention to
that but even now it's still people very
much Overlook that and you you overlook
then a large part of your life you don't
give it
attention when I say give attention
there's an element of appreciation of
everything of the little things and you
begin to realize that your entire life
consists mainly of little things
nonattachment to things does not mean
not
appreciating
things but it means
not seeking
yourself or to
regard thing things as an extension of
yourself or think of things as needing
them to add to
yourself in order to be yourself more
fully that's attachment to
things it's an an
ego dysfunction but in in way in which
the ego survives
and it's it's not pleasant because you
always need more and nothing really
satisfies you when if ever
you buy something and seek some kind of
self satisfaction through it very
quickly you realize it doesn't work and
then you look for something
else however there is a way of
appreciating things beautiful things or
simple things appreciate is not being
attached you can love even
love a piece of furniture or whatever it
is a little object or a piece of
something you wear too not saying all
this needs to disappear you can you can
like things and appreciate them love
them in a sense of having
appreciate
it without the without
the self-seeking in
it and when it the thing leaves
you it's you you lose it or it breaks
or it gets stolen or
whatever without the attachment you'll
say oh it's a Pity but you don't there's
no reaction and no pain you're able to
let go and that's a sign that something
you appreciate and yet when it's not
there anymore well that's all right
to I always appreciate it
since
I I started in my between the age of 30
and well up to the age of 30 I don't
know 36
my my main transportation was
bicycle and I always had a I always
appreciated my
bicycle
uh and I developed a strange
habit when I parked my bicycle and
changed it to something a railing
outside
whatever I would take a few steps and
look back on it and and just appreciate
it's its being it's a very strange habit
you look back at it and look back one
more time there it
is and sometimes people ask why are you
looking back at your bicycle are you
proud of it well it wasn't a
particularly special bicycle just a
normal no it just I I appreciate it it
being
there and
uh one
when then I got an I Got a Car somebody
gave me an old car and then I lent my
bicycle to somebody and one and suddenly
that person came and said I'm so sorry I
lost your
bike I didn't lock it for a few minutes
and now it's
gone and it I had already gone through a
shift in Consciousness so I it's okay
it's gone nothing we can do about it
hopefully somebody else appreciates it
now
then I develop the same habit with my
old car I would look back when it I
parked it I'd look back and just
appreciate it being there and I do the
same now that I have a much better car
and now with my good car people think I
must be proud of this car or something
but it's not that I did the same with
the
bicycle it's a strange habit I'm not
recommending anybody that he should do
that but it's just it's a one a way in
which I appreciate it it its being in
this world dealing with
things creating things achieving
things and being is
about being aware
of the present
moment
which after all is all you ever
have whatever you achieve through
becoming in the future
eventually turns into the present
moment so as I speak to
you the meditation if we even want to
call it
that it's perhaps best to forget about
the
word as I
speak be aware of
the St the silence or the
Stillness between the
words
being aware means just notice that it's
there it's very
simple so you notice
that in addition to the
words there's another
dimension that is easily
overlooked
and that's the dimension
of
Stillness which we could also
call
space
or
spaciousness
so when you
notice that there are
two so to
speak two
Dimensions
here the dimension
of
Words which
you
hear and which then become
thoughts in your
head
and the dimension
of
no
spaciousness you just so you just notice
that's all that's
required
that there is that Dimension also
present so you notice
it in between
words and
even behind the
words so to
speak now when you notice
it what
happens inside you what does it mean to
notice the
Stillness be aware of the
Stillness it
means you have become still
inside it
means you're
conscious but at that moment at this
moment you're not
thinking but you're
aler
present completely
here but not
thinking
so that's the
realization of the dimension of
depths
within you we may be surprised to know
that there are millions billions of
people on the planet who have that same
thought pattern there's something wrong
with me it's part of the human
ego but so you bring in the
awareness and that will change
everything that's the only true
key if you fail then next time you the
anger
arises what happens you will become
aware immediately after the anger has
subsided and then oh there it was and I
wasn't
present and then the the the moment will
come when you are there in the first if
you can catch the anger the first moment
it
comes or if you might even see that it's
could be the result of a thought that
creates the anger and if you can be
there in the first moment before it
becomes to fully blown anger then you
can stay there and it might not even
become fully blown anger if you catch it
the first moment you can feel the first
stirrings of anger you may only have 3
seconds you may come very quickly anger
is like an explosive energy you may only
have two three four 5 Seconds to to to
bring the stay there with your awareness
and feel it oh it's coming there it is
that's the pain body the angry pain body
coming and if you catch it in the early
stage don't suppress it by catch it I
mean feel it be there as a witness then
you can stay even as it grows the
witness grows with it it may not even
grow will have to see whether it still
grows into full-blown anger or not that
doesn't
matter and so you be thankful for your
anger
because the anger can be become a very
important spiritual practice for you
because through it awareness can
grow so it's it's a sometimes strange
for people to see you can be thankful
for things that you think are the most
difficult obstacles in your life but
they
become they can become the greatest
opportunity for for Spiritual Awakening
use it as part of your practice life
without love is no life at
all now what does that mean life without
love love can only be there when you're
connected to the source of
Life who you are Beyond
form still
spaciousness and then from
there you
perceive you
relate you operate you do what you
do
and there's a sense of Oneness no longer
sense of Separation you're one with the
present
moment you're one with whoever you meet
because the separation comes through con
mental
Concepts and that sense of Oneness is
love it's a recognition
that you
share with every life form you
share the same
Consciousness so it's always a self
recognition you see you sense rather
than see yourself in the other that is
love my North Star is the monk the story
you shared about the monk who lived
saying is that so for everything that
came I am
trying my best to get there in my
journey to accepting the isness of
things and accepting the moment what I'm
struggling with
is when am I being a doormat how do I
determine it's clear in the example you
just shared being homeless in the gray
area of Life how do I determine when I
need to take action the important thing
is non-resistance is not so much to do
what externally what you do but it's an
it's an inner state of consciousness of
non-resistance acceptance of what is of
the present moment in this this moment
um it doesn't if it's misunderstood then
it could lead as you say it could lead
you to become a doormat because then you
would go along with with what everybody
say anybody says to you uh and you would
can you do this can you do this for me
yeah okay I can do it and then you you
could be used by
people uh
H but a state of non of
non-resistance
sometimes
um may require you to say no to let's
say somebody requests something but you
feel you don't want to do it or you
cannot do
it uh for some reason and you say
no I I don't I think I wrote about this
I I had this
expression a high quality
no as opposed to a low quality no a low
quality no is you make the other person
into uh kind of enemies and why you
always ask me this
like youed to argue
and you accuse the other you're just
trying to use me I can see it you've
used me before and now you're doing it
again now you're asking me for money
again I've already lent you five times
have you given it back to me no you
haven't so no I'm not going to do it
just don't leave me alone that's one
no and then there's another no which is
nonreactive it's not AR does not arise
from reactivity but is a response to the
situation that says uh no I don't want
to let's say whatever the request is or
the demand no I I can't do it anymore I
don't want to do it anymore no I'm not
going to give you money again because
I've already given you five times so
this I'm I won't give you again uh
that's just how it is I no I can't uh no
no I
[Music]
canot whatever it may be you're saying
no without creating an enemy without
treating or a situation without making a
situation into an
enemy so it's a conscious know and
you're still in an inner state of
non-resistance the state of resistance
strengthens the ego and this is a way of
not operating through not operating
through ego so I wonder could to connect
that to what I'm doing with this month
um I I suppose someone like you kind of
kind of digs something like this the
idea that someone could put down the
devices and I wonder what what do you
think just in general about a world that
is so obsessively connected to other
people's thoughts all day long yes
that's good so uh um the over this um
excessive identification with thinking
and overthinking excessive thinking had
been there for a long time long before
we came up with these
devices but uh these devices uh amplify
the human tendency to to engage or
indulge in excessive thinking and
problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking Focus thinking uh
so the what you are doing uh is very
very helpful you are basically uh uh
having a period of what we could call it
decluttering your mind you declutter
your mind and this is necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
been been as cluttered as they are now
now uh clut means there's a continuous
input of stuff that comes in through the
devices uh the messages come in Facebook
posts uh tweets and continuously the
devices demand your attention and say
this is important and a lot of it is not
important but as we all
know there's an addictive qu to it it
draws your attention to it and then
every time it draws your attention you
add to the Clutter of your mind a lot of
that is not
constructive a lot of it is just random
people often see people they get out
their phones and they do this random
scrolling I can see it's random there's
nothing specific but they think they
have to do it because everybody else is
doing it around them wherever you are
these days people are engaging with this
and they're continuously taking in
thoughts from others and as we said
before some of these thoughts may be
toxic and they may easily become lodged
in your
mind uh so to declutter is extremely
important uh and you can see if you even
just not using a device for a day for
many people is very very
hard uh and some think they can do it
but they can't so they are truly
addicted um now when you when you when
you declutter your mind first of all you
put down your phone you don't use it not
everybody can do it for whole months
like you of course of course but I
recommend to everybody to have certain
periods of time when they uh do not
engage so for example in your bedroom
might be a good place to T for not
engaging with any any device uh certain
periods of time when you go out into
nature be there rather than carry that
thing and every time it makes a noise
you still look up and you still even
while you're surrounded by Beauty and
aliveness you're still engaging with
this and the moment you watch the screen
whether it's television or what of
screen you might have noticed that the
your own your so-called own thought
processes come to a stop so to some
extent you're free of the self this is
why people sometimes find watching
television relaxing say okay I just need
to relax now let's turn it on by this
they mean while they watch the
television screen they're not burdened
by their self induced thought processes
what they do however they
replace the their own Thoughts with the
collective thoughts so they just they in
a state you're not in a state of
thoughtless awareness when you watch
television or you watch something on the
screen you
absorb the thoughts from there into your
mind and you you link into so it for
people often in a state of semi or
hypnosis when they watch and it kind of
paralyzes you can also happen with the
screen with television already started
of course um don't know when whenever
tell 60 years ago whenever television
started and you
go and so your mind is just absorbing
whatever is playing it's the TV mind
which is receiving stuff from wh it
comes from is going into your mind and
you become
a no longer thinking your own thoughts
occasionally your mind you say oh this
guy is so stupid and then you're
watching
again
and then another thought why am I
watching this
rubbish half an hour
later this is so
awful but you can't you can't can't turn
it off here's the here's the
remote let's let's just try one more
Channel there might be something else
there
oh no that's stupid try one
more this is this is how an addict
behaves and the device is even more
addictive you go because you carry them
with
you and uh you have to admit you may
have to admit that you there is an
addiction in you not everybody here but
quite a few it would be almost normal to
feel this draw towards it and you use it
even when you don't need to use it
that's the amazing thing when you're
standing at the
elevator
waiting another person is standing next
to you and he or she is pulling out the
phone and then you pull out yours you
don't know
why and or anywhere you in a you all
have all waiting your ordering a tea or
coffee somewhere and you're standing in
line and if you look around there's
almost nobody and probably nobody who is
not looking at this little
thing this is
scary zombie like the
feeling first of all needs to be
acknowledged and
accepted uh you can't start with letting
go so we have to start with
acknowledging
it and accepting that it's there because
it's part of what is the isness of the
present moment whether it's an external
thing or an inner thing it it is what
is and to deny or to argue with what is
creates
suffering so
you acknowledge you accept that it's
there
then how much time you
need to be with
it depends various from person to person
and what what kind of a feeling it is
and so
[Music]
on and then the question arises what is
the link between between that feeling
and your thought
processes
the person needs to find
out whether the thought
[Music]
processes keep that feeling alive
continuously whether they renew by
playing out for example a past scenario
in their minds by
Reviving memories from the past by
dwelling on certain narratives that are
painful repeating them in their minds
that gives Renewed Energy to the feeling
MH so the first the most important thing
is to beware of both levels what's the
level of my thinking how does that
contribute to the perpetuation of what I
feel and so you also then acknowledge
that oh the these are the habitual
thought patterns that go through my mind
in relation to the
feelings and then the you would begin to
realize
that the Letting Go the most important
step in letting go of feelings is to cut
the link between your thinking and what
you're feeling how do you do that you do
it it
by by being aware of your thinking and
realizing that that thinking is pain it
feeds the old feeling and the narrative
whatever it is is a painful
narrative and you realize that you've
been keeping it alive for some
years and you when you there's some
enough awareness you realize that it it
has no
purpose except to make you unhappy and
to perpetuate that
feeling when you're in nature you may be
looking at something uh whatever it may
be
[Music]
uh but then you can also take in the
totality of where you are what whatever
it may
be your surroundings
trees mountains the ocean or just simple
a l a grassy
surface
bushes take in the totality and
[Music]
then bring in other sense perceptions
too but that requires alertness so that
you don't drift back into mental cont
Concepts stay alert then you bring in
become aware not just of the visual
aspect of being there you become aware
of the sounds there may be sounds
natural sounds or there may be sounds
that are not natural that are
interfering but that's fine there may be
natural
sounds a breeze you can
hear the
wind the the leaves are moving in the
wind or the
so
[Music]
Birds who knows all natural
sounds then there's
also the air you can feel the air
perhaps is a very slight movement of air
you can feel it on your skin and then
you there's a sense of you
smell n there's a certain sense arise as
you be become aware of your sense of
smell
maybe you can smell the the moisture in
the ground
or be be there with all your
senses all
senses you can also for for a few
moments close your eyes so that you can
more focus on the other sentence that
tend to be neglected from many
people so you just take in
your you smell the
air you you feel the slight breeze on
your
skin
sounds it's a beautiful experience and
you don't need to look for always the
spectacular in nature sometimes nature
can be very spectacular but a lot of the
time it's just ordinary things yes
sometimes you have a beautiful
incredible flower or
gigantic Sequoia tree or whatever um
incredible
things but and many other times there's
just normal nature there nothing that
that says
pay attention to me so you have to find
if you're alert enough you will see
the this
the concealed in the
ordinary spectacle of nature there is an
extraordinary
aliveness and beingness and presence you
so you don't have don't always look for
the one the great
thing just to be aware of all many
things that one would habitually
Overlook in a normal State of
Consciousness it's just there's a bush
there there's a grass here it's been
cut
all nothing
special but if you really come
alert then you
see everything is intensely
alive it there's a Consciousness there
it may not be self-conscious not
conscious of itself there is a
Consciousness that has manifested as the
tree the
flower the grass the bush there's a
Consciousness that has
manifested in that
form a different vibrational frequency
one could say to your
Consciousness but it's not your
Consciousness there only only one
universal Consciousness manifesting in
countless life
forms so you begin to recognize because
but only because you you know yourself
as Consciousness your mind has become
still
enough for you to know yourself as
Consciousness you you sense the
Consciousness that is inseparable from
who you are that is the essence of who
you are that is who you
are and then you can you can sense the
Consciousness in other the life forms be
aware of
the conceptualizing your
life and
allowing an unhappy
story in your
head to make you
unhappy people think they're unhappy
because of the circumstances of their
lives in most cases they're
unhappy because
of what they're telling themselves so
what the mind is saying about what's
going on around you and has happened
will
happen so that's a it's a
suffering the origin of suffering to
large extent is there and even in
extreme situations having lost your home
for
example not knowing where to
live you even there it
applies you do not in the face of a
challenge if you are
present you don't convert the challenge
into
suffering you just be with what
is and you start experimenting with
little things in your life that cause
you
irritation or a little bit of anger or
some
impatience situations that are very
common every
day and you look at the situation you
become aware suddenly that there's
irritation arising or anger
arising and you become aware that it
doesn't actually feel very good the body
knows it doesn't feel good the body
doesn't like
it there's irritation arising and you
think it's because of what's going on
but if you look more closely think now
is this situation causing this or is
what I'm saying about it causing this
what my mind the commentary of my
mind and in most cases you will find
it's the mental commentary that you had
been identified with that causes the
unhappiness and then you say let's
experiment with removing the commentary
how would I experience this situation if
I did not ADD the mental baggage to
it so in other words you're just now
with the isness of this
moment without any thing mental stuff
added being added to it that says this
should not be happening I don't want to
be here and many other
things
suddenly you're
fine a minute
ago you were extremely irritated and
angry and you you couldn't differentiate
between the
circumstances external circumstan of
your life and the inner commentary about
the
circumstances and this is the essence of
unconsciousness
unable to differentiate between the
circumstances and the
commentary so the circumstances and the
commentary become single is are
experienced as a single
phenomenon and then when you suddenly
you can
separate this is the isness of this
moment and it is as it is enormous power
is suddenly arising in you which is the
power of the present moment which is The
Power Of unconditioned Consciousness
also the power of dealing with a
situation if there's something that you
need to do suddenly right action as the
Buddha calls it right action happens or
non-action if action is not possible
then right surrender
happens but you allow this moment to be
as it is without but what does it mean
means you don't add unnecessary mental
baggage to it that argues with the
isness of this moment usually happiness
exists as part of the play of opposites
you experience the happiness because
something makes you happy and then that
thing that made you happy either leaves
you or the very thing that made you
happy suddenly makes you
unhappy marriage for example
[Music]
or a
relationship before you start living
together you're happy when you start
living together you
unhappy so what is if it's not happy
what are we talking about
the there's
a
if
you let go of thinking and remain as the
awareness then there is in that that
awareness emanates a certain peace
aive
peace joy peace the peace ful joyful
sense of
aliveness inner peace may be a better
word than happiness but one would have
to add to it it's an alive piece it's
not the piece of uh having deadened
yourself to
emotions or anything like that it's an
alive intensely alive piece you can
sense
it even if it's only just a glimpse
right now
surrender
thought and of
course right now if you're not thinking
about the problems of your life there
are no problems in this moment there's
only a sense of beingness or
liveness and that is the connectedness
with
being and so you transcend the Opposites
between happiness and unhappiness
adversity
can either it can strengthen the
ego or it can gradually or in some cases
suddenly dissolve the ego or at least
diminish it it can go either way and I
must agree with you I don't know whether
you have literally said it in perhaps
still in the majority of cases it
strengthens the ego because nobody know
people don't know the opportunity that
every adversity represents so why does
it happen how does it strengthen the ego
you can see it sometimes with people who
are sick or people who are disabled who
let's say I've met disabled people
people with physical disabilities for
example and in some cases they are
very really angry with the world and
bitter because look at what happened to
me they say why do I can't move anymore
I've been Afflicted with this what have
I done to deserve this and these are all
questions that are the the justifiable
questions the the question what what
have I done to deserve why has the world
or whatever they say God the world the
universe or whoever they done this to me
why and then they become bitter and
angry and the E ego becomes more and
more rigid and hardened and
[Music]
and and that is one way it could go and
then I have met people with
disabilities who through their
disability at some point whether through
a spiritual teaching and in some cases
never come into contact with any
spiritual teaching it just happened that
at some moment they realized
intuitively that all the
suffering was
generated through
resistance and then the resistance to
the isness of their life this
moment they were able to let go because
perhaps the suffering was getting too
much something happened
something clicked
inside or even if it didn't happen
completely uh they were able to have
moments of uh inner peace an inner peace
that is not caused by an external
condition an inner peace that seems to
be in cont contradiction to an external
condition so that they would way how
could a person
who is suffering this feel so peaceful
and so
um also that applies to people who are
um approaching the end of their lifespan
because they have some illness and they
have been to the doctor and the doctor
says you have six months or one year and
and
suddenly something in then opens up and
all that remains is
the the person already dies there's no
more future and All That Remains is the
present moment and the the aware space
so I've had the privilege of working
with when I was still seeing
individuals with two or three people to
whom that
happened and they became luminous beings
in the last few weeks or months of their
lives and became
just there was no wasn't I couldn't see
that there was any person left there was
only a space of conscious presence left
just wonderful as if they had just come
into this world so they came and then
they came to me and then still asking
questions very profound questions
wanting to understand what happened and
it's
beautiful so this can happen it can
happen collectively to people who
have who go through Warfare and and in
countries or become refugees they lose
everything and again it can go either
way uh whenever there's any great loss
in your life that again an opportunity
opens up if if you resist and you you
resist U the resistance origin the
origin of the resistance is a narrative
that forms in your
mind uh that says something about the
sitation and about your life and about
other people uh so the narrative forms
in your mind and the narrative is an
unhappy one and then there's continuous
resistance and nonalignment with the
isness of the present moment now one
could ask well how could somebody who
has lost who's lost their home perhaps
even lost love loved
ones and then they don't know where to
go how could would this person be in a
state of alignment with the pro present
moment isn't that how can how can
somebody accept be
unacceptable except that which in
conventional terms would be regarded as
unacceptable how is that how is that
possible but that's precisely it if you
can accept the unacceptable that is the
sudden the opening and then you realize
the unacceptable is actually not
unacceptable it is
acceptable and the I was homeless for a
certain period in my life with not
knowing what what to live on
the next day or the next week and uh uh
I had already gone into the state of
acceptance so it was a very pleasant
experience but potentially would have
been extremely unpleasant so not having
a home was for me already something that
was not experienced as something bad but
I knew I had to take some action
eventually to to get a home and so
gradually something happen I don't want
to talk too much about that I also
mentioned in
the new us I believe um there when I was
at University there was
the stepen Hawkins the physicist who was
confined to a wheelchair who passed away
couple of years ago when there it was um
he would always he wasn't famous at that
time only famous locally in the
University we would always be in the
same dining room having lunch but not
the same table I never met him wasn't
introduced observed him many times C at
a neighboring table and I and I the one
moment when I hold H open the door for
him he was coming through on his
wheelchair
and I looked into his eyes and I could
see there was no unhappiness when
you want
to strengthen the physical
body what do you
do you
exercise but what what is that actually
when you exercise what do you do when
you
exercise one way of putting it is to say
that you
create difficulty for the
body you create obstacles for the body
to
overcome whatever it is running on the
TR lifting
weight it's and you're creating a a
difficulty for the body any exercise is
making life difficult for the
body that's a way of looking at it
that's not a normal way of looking at
it you take the body out of its comfort
zone although there is a stage where the
body once it gets going the body may
enjoy the energy of it but until that
flows there's a discomfort
and that's the only
way the body can get
stronger
if the body stays in its comfort zone
then well you would be lying on a sofa
or in a deck
chair it's very nice but the body
doesn't
change
so that's an
interesting almost an analogy for
something that
happens to
humans because it seems that life for
everybody creates
difficulties so it's not one would have
thought if I were
God I would make life easy for
everybody
and you will then
see most likely if you did that most
likely there would
be no Evolution would ever have
happened or no further Evolution if you
do it right
now
because it's only it seems both on the
physical level and
Beyond it's only through facing
difficulties which you could also call
challenges which you could also call
problems if you like which you could
also call one damn thing after
another the strange thing is only by
encountering these
challenges do we grow in Consciousness
and
generate energy it awakens us eventually
for some incredible Bruce Lipton
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I have a memory of a point in my
life where that changed just like boom
just like Tom ready turned to switch
because I I was on the edge of I could
have been diagnosed as manic depressive
well it happy most of the time but once
it started going wrong then was like
this is wrong